les réseaux sociaux ont contribué à
libérer la parole mais le constat est là
ils ont aussi banalisé l'insulte et
l'invective chez bon nombre de leur
utilisateurs la preuve à l'instant avec
ce documentaire réalisé par Hélène
lamtrang harcèlement propos xénophobe
propos antisémite propos islamophobe
pourquoi tant de haine en ligne et
surtout quels sont les moyens d'y mettre
un terme nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débadoc en commençant par
vous jeannoël barreau bienvenue vous
êtes ministre délégué chargé du
numérique et vice-président du Mouvement
Démocrate le modem au sein du
gouvernement vous avez notamment porté
un projet de loi visant à sécuriser et
réguler l'espace numérique c'est un
texte qui est toujours en cours d'examen
à l'Assemblée nationale il a été voté
par le Sénat il vient d'être nommé
d'être voté aussi du côté de l'Assemblée
nationale mais mais mais le verdict
final ça sera pour décembre prochain à
l'occasion d'une commission mixte parit
ou sénateurs et députés se mettront
d'accord on l'espère sur un texte commun
Justine Atland est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes la directrice
générale de l'association Enfance
reconnue d'utilité publique dans sa
mission de protection de l'enfance sur
Internet et d'éducation à la citoyenneté
numérique et puis enfin François Saltiel
est également avec nous bienvenue vous
êtes journaliste auteur réalisateur euh
producteur votre chronique entre autres
un monde connecté est à écouter chaque
jour de la semaine chez nos confrères de
France Culture et votre dernier livre
s'intitule la société su sans contact
c'est le fi d'un monde en chute
disponible aux éditions flamarion ce ne
sont plus les plateformes qui font la
loi mais la loi qui doit faire plier les
plateformes avez-vous dit dans une
interview que j'ai eu l'occasion de de
lire en préparant cette émission on va y
revenir bien sûr et c'est dans cétat
d'esprit je crois que vous avez
travaillé Jean-Noël barreau mais pour
commencer on va voir tout de suite et
d'emblé un premier extrait du
documentaire il concerne justement le
problème de ces fameuses plateformes
alors l'attitude des plateformes elle
est elle est peut-être le problème
majeur il faut bien voir queaujourd'hui
Twitter ne collabore pas ne collabore
plus Twitter c'est une société de droit
californien qui invoque le premier
amendement américain je vous rappelle
qu'aux États-Unis vous pouvez sortir
dans la rue être habillé en Asie et
faire un un salut hitlerrien vous ne
serez jamais poursuivi le droit
américain ne connaît pas d'abus de la
liberté d'expression et c'est justement
euh la liberté d'expression qui s'agit
de de réguler aujourd'hui face à ces
monstres hein que sont les les gfemes
c'est un bras de fer en réalité hein qui
est en train de de s'engager avec ses
opérateurs américains pour la plupart on
peut regretter qu'il n'y ait pas de G
FAM européen on en parlera peut-être
tout à l'heure en tout cas la réaction
européenne est arrivée avec ce qu'on
appelle le digital service Act hein qui
est en œuvre depuis le 25 août dernier
partout dans l'Union europém et qui doit
permettre de protéger les internautes
contre les propos aineux et les
opérations des informations en ligne
c'est c'est effectivement pleinement
notre sujet c'est le sujet qui est
soulevé par le film que nous venons de
voir ça c'est la réponse européenne au
bras de fer qu'il faut engager avec ces
fameuses plateformes essentiellement
américaines c'est bien ça oui après une
vingtaine d'années pendant lesquelles
ces grandes plateformes euh se sont
retranché se sont cachés derrière les
différences de nos législations
rgl sacinte liberté d'expression pour ne
pas payer d'impôt et pour échapper à
toutes nos règles et il faut reconnaître
que depuis quelques années depuis 5 ans
les choses ont changé grâce à la France
notamment grâce au président de la
République en a fait une une une cause
de de nos de nos batailles européennes
et nous avons en matière fiscale mis fin
à cette situation qui consistait pour
les géants du numérique à s'installer
aller systématiquement en Irlande ou
parfois au Luxembourg pour échapper à
l'impôt et nous avons mis fin avec ce
règlement le le DSA le Règlement sur les
services numériques qui fait sortir les
grandes plateformes de leur situation
d'irresponsabilité total vis-à-vis des
contenus qui transitent sur leurs
interfaces parce que il y a 20 ans quand
ces plateformes ont émergé la manière
dont elles ont été régulé a consisté à
dire que euh Facebook Twitter Instagram
et les autres n'ont pas à connaître des
messages qui transitent sur leur service
et que si il y a des des messages qui
sont illicite parce qu'ils sont porteurs
de violence de haine de cyberhcèlement
et cetera c'est la faute des auteurs et
ça n'est pas la faute de la plateforme
et bien en européen l'année dernière
quand la France présidait l'Union
européenne nous avons dit stop et nous
avons dit que les plateformes elles
doivent exercer ou avoir une
responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'impact
qu'elles ont sur la société et depuis
quelques semaines depuis le 25 août pour
les plus grandes d'entre elles de
nouvelles obligations s'imposent à elles
quel que soit le lieu où elles sont
implantées en Europe elles doivent désor
obligation en terme de euh régulation
elles doivent désormais elles doivent
désormais retirer les contenus les
messages à caractère illicite qui leur
sont signalés soit par les utilisateurs
soit par des associations comme il
enfants soit par euh les autorités elles
doivent euh partager leurs données avec
des chercheurs doivent faire auditer
leurs algorithmes elles doivent
s'abstenir de faire de la publicité sur
les mineurs et puis il y a une nouvelle
règle règle qui est très importante
c'est qu'elles doivent analyser et
corriger le risque qu'elles font peser
sur la santé de leurs utilisateurs on
pense à l'addiction chez les plus jeunes
sur la le discours civique on pense à la
propagation de fausses nouvelles et sur
la sécurité publi et là on pense au
dévoiement des réseaux sociaux notamment
pendant la période des violences
urbaines du début du mois de juillet et
ça c'est c'est très important parce que
pour la première fois dans l'histoire du
monde ces plateformes ont une
responsabilité non pas vis-à-vis des
messages uniquement et et leur
obligation de retrait mais aussi
vis-à-vis de l'impact que leurs
algorithmes que leur fonctionnement même
va avoir sur la société alors ce
règlement est entré en vigueur la
question en réalité la seule question
c'est est-ce qui va pouvoir être
appliquer est-ce que les
sanctions la Commission européenne que
la Commission européenne va pouvoir
prononcer ouais oui parce que la carotte
c'est l'accès plein et entier au marché
européen le bon et le bâton c'est la
sanction 6 % du chiffre d'affaires
mondial c'est-à-dire pour une entreprise
comme Twitter à peu près 300 millions
d'euros pour une entreprise comme TikTok
à peu près 600 millions d'euros d'amende
potentielou et en cas de manquement
répété à ces obligations nouvelles le
bâton peut aller jusqu'à l'exclusion
jusqu'au bannissement de l'Union EUR je
vois que ça fait réagir tout de suite de
l'autre côté de cette table oui non non
non je l'intention effectivement est
c'est un Act fondateur vous êtes
d'accord c'est un acte fondateur et et
là où je trouve ça intéressant c'est
qu'entre le temps technologique et le
temps législatif il y avait toujours un
grand écart c'est que la technologie va
très vite et le temps législatif est
très long c'est normal c'est donc on a
mis très longtemps à réagir du côté de
l'Union euréne voilà donc là avec le DSA
qui est effectivement rentré en vigueur
à la fin du mois d'août sa que là on a
un cas concret en ce moment c'estàd
qu'on a le conflit entre Israël et le
Hamas je pense que c'est quand on est
utilisateur des réseaux sociaux on est
tous submergés par un flot d'information
on est submergé par de la désin
formation on parle de brouillard
informationnel et là on voit bien que le
DSA va jouer à mon sens ici déjà un
premier acte très fort et sa crédibilité
parce que pour l'instant effectivement
il n'est pas encore appliqué on sait que
il pourrait être appliqué début 2024 le
temps que tous les coordinateurs des 27
pays se rerou pour faire appliquer le
règlement alors on sait qu'on veut
accélérer justement cette question là
parce que j'aienvie d'4 c'est quasiment
un autre monde il peut s'en passer des
choses jusque là mais pour l'instant on
voit bien que la désinformation
prolifère abondamment sur les réseaux
sociaux et si on prend un un exemple qui
est celui de Twitter aujourd'hui baptisé
X et Elon Musk on voit que la manière
dont il se comporte c'estàd qu'il a
quand même sacrifié son service de
modération sait à quel point les
modérateurs sont un un endroit vraiment
très important pour pouvoir arriver à
réguler ses
messages exactement donc là il a c'est
quand même un acte qui va pas forcément
dans le bon sens et puis on voit bien
qu'entre lui et Thierry Breton donc le
commissaire au numérique au niveau
européen il se joue aussi un peu de lui
en lui disant qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que tu me reproches vraiment je vais
voir ce que je vais faire enfin on sait
qu'il est un peu fantasque donc le le
règlement est là mais il va jouer sa
crédibilité prochainement et et il
faudrait pas qu'il soit morné si on veut
aller aller vite il faudrait qu'il passe
qu'il puisse véritablement s'appliquer
et pour l'instant se l'avenir nous le
dira ouais c'est très important parce
que dans la période qu'on vit euh on
peut espérer qu'à l'avenir mais c'est
vrai que ça n'est pas encore possible
euh la Commission européenne puisse
exercer l'une des prérogatives que lui
donne ce règlement et qui est très
importante c'est dans l'article 36 de
règlement il y a euh une possibilité qui
est donnée à la commission euh d'exiger
en cas de crise grave des plateformes
qu'ell modifient profondément le
fonctionnement de leurs algorithmes pour
éviter les troubl à l'ordre public à la
santé publique et cetera autrement dit
dans une situation comme celle qu'on a
connu ces derniers jours ouais où l'on
voit euh proliférer sur les réseaux
sociaux des contenus illicites euh
d'apologie du terrorisme euh de violence
manifestes qui pent atteinte à la
dignité ou à l'intégrité des personnes
on peut très bien imaginer que la
commission mais effectivement ça sera
pas avant février 2024 puisse exiger des
plateformes qu'ell déviralis
qu'elle invisibilise ces contenusl euh
le temps évidemment de pouvoir les
traiter et que là il y a un problème de
aussi de temporalité parce qu'on sait
très bien que la viralité on l'a vu
aussi dans le documentaire d'une fausse
information le temps qu'on réagisse elle
a déjà été partagée des millions de fois
donc s'il faut attendre février 2024
pour lutter contre la désinformation
mais d'un autre côté l'Europe est la
première démocratie du monde à avoir
imposé de telles règles au géants du
numérique et le monde entier est en
train de regarder si ce règlement va
pouvoir être appliqué pour peut-être
s'en inspirer ouis et j'ai vu quelque
part vous aviez particulièrement dans le
collimateur x un Twitter racheté par
Elon Musk concernant le le conflit entre
Israël et le Hamas he que vous avez et
vous aussi d'aurs il y a déjà trois
enquêtes je précise en attendant que la
Commission puisse déclencher son
mécanisme de crise elle a en attendant
déclenché trois enquêtes sur Twitter sur
Instagram sur Facebook et sur TikTok et
elle a aussi invité les États-membres
dont la France fait partie à faire à lui
faire
remonter les constat de contenu qui
seraiit contraire au droit français mais
qui ne serait pas retiré et je vais
moi-même réunir dans quelques jours un
certain nombre d'associations et
d'administrations qui participent à la
détection de ces contenus illicites
alors signalement à à ces grandes
plateformes pour faire un état des lieux
avec ell de tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis 15 jours pour pouvoir ensuite sur
la base de ce constat quelle plateforme
a joué le jeu à quelle vitesse ou non
transférer le tout à la Commission
européenne pour alimenter ces enquêtes
donc à suivre hein je inatelant cette
violence c'est harcellement et là on
parle notamment du harcèlement scolaire
he c'est ce qui parce que ça aussi c'est
au-dessus de la table du côté du
gouvernement également avec Gabriel Atal
qui entend frapper très fort sur pour
combattre le harcèlement scolaire et ce
harcèlement scolaire il a lieu dans les
établissements scolaires mais il a lieu
surtout en dehors des établissements
scolaires à cause hein des réseaux
sociaux est-ce que ce digital service
Act trouve des réponses à vos attentes
concernant la protection des enfants
l'éducation des enfants au numérique euh
est-ce que vous y trouvez de quoi être
rassuré
euh pour la suite concernant
euh les deux à la fois les deux à la
fois faut reconnaître que la Commission
européenne a été assez précurseur sur la
protection de l'enfance en ligne avant
le DSA la Commission européenne a mis en
place des programmes euh des Helpline
dont nous faisons partie puisque
l'association Enfance opère laplan
française qui justement permet de
signaler aux plateformes ben des cas de
de de mineurs enfants ou adolescents qui
sont en danger sur sur leur plateforme
et et ça c'est un système qui a été mis
en place de façon je dirais volontaire
collaborative proactive par la
Commission européenne depuis un certain
nombre d'années donc je dirais que la
protection de l'enfance en ligne a
permis de tester aussi un certain nombre
de fonctionnements qui maintenant sont
modélisé et finalement sanctuarisé
quelque part dans un texte européen qui
est le DSA puisque typiquement on va
sans doute être être être reconnu comme
ce qu'on appelle un signaleur de
confiance dont parlait le ministre tout
à l'heure qui sont ces associations
intermédires entre les utilisateurs et
les plateformes pour pouvoir signaler de
façon très efficace très rapide pour
vraiment répondre à ces questions de
viralité et leur demander un retrait
très rapide donc tout ça pour dire qu'il
y a quand même eu des choses qui se sont
construites de façon volontaire
proactive avec une petite incitation
forte de l'Europe évidemment mais mais
qui ont pu être testés donc maintenant
on connaît un peu ce qui marche et ce
qui marche pas là où il va falloir
appuyer et cetera est-ce que qui
connaissez parfaitement bien ce domaine
est-ce que les solutions techniques pour
la mise en œuvre de tout ce qui vient
d'être dit
auparavant sont également sur la table
est-ce que tout cela est faisable
techniquement ch que techniquement
aujourd'hui bah techniquement le
problème qu'on a c'est un un
déséquilibre de de maîtrise de la
technique c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
dans le DSA il y a cette idée de de
qu'enfin on connaisse davantage les
algorithmes qu'enfin effectivement les
plateformes ouvre justement leurs API
enfin puisse permettre aux chercheurs de
de comprendre comment fonctionnent les
algorithmes alors ça va être fait de
façon très fléchée donc faut pas arriver
malheureusement on n'arrivera pas à voir
tout tout le temps mais on pourra de
voilà ouvrir selon des thématiques et
des sujets mais mais il reste quand même
un déséquilibre très fort de
connaissance de maîtrise de ces
algorithmes et du fonctionnement de ces
outils qui est vrai dans un rapport
entre le politique et ses entreprises et
ça ça reste encore malgré tout assez
déséquilibré faut reconnaître ce qu'il
est qui reste évidemment très fort entre
utilisateurs et ses entreprises et ça
c'est sansout un autre sujet qui est
abordé dans le documentaire et qui est
très important c'est qu'on voit bien que
les gens ne comprennent rien aux réseaux
sociaux ne savent pas où ils sont ne
savent pas comment ça fonctionne et
c'est aussi ce qui participe au fait
qu'ils se font complètement avoir et
embarquer dans un monde dont
ilimpression ils ne comprennent vraiment
pas où ils sont à quoi ils servent et
comment l'information leur arrive donc
effectivement nécessairement ça laisse
place à de la crédulité à de
l'embrasement un certain nombre de
choses donc voilà il y a il faut
vraiment appuyer sur cette information
cette éducation elle concerne pas que
les enfants elle concerne la société en
général tous les acteurs que nous sommes
à connaître le mieux possible le
fonctionnement de ces entreprises qui de
toute façon je trouve que c'est ce qui
est assez flagrant dans le documentaire
un jour elles vont elles-mêm mourir de
ce qu'elles ont créé si elles continuent
comme ça parce qu'en fait ce qu'elle
génère va détruire le modèle dans lequel
elles sont nées et je pense qu'elles
vont qu'elles vont y perdre alors je
sais pas s'il faut qu'on atteind ce cet
endroitl ultime de tension pour qu'elle
réagisse mais je pense qu'elles ont
l'intelligence de le savoir et que donc
peut-être on est aussi arrivé à un
moment où elles ont compris qu'il faut
qu'ell collabore et que et que elles
vont se sauver elles-mêm ça reste des
entreprise donc effectivement nappuyons
pas sur il y a un récent rapport de
l'arcom qui dit qu'on y est pas encore
concernant la mise en œuvre de de ce
fameux digital service Act à suivre donc
puisque la mise en œuvre va
va le projet de loi visant à sécuriser
et réguler l'espace numérique c'est
votre projet de loi je l'ai dit il a été
voté au Sénat voté à l'Assemblée
nationale euh le fin du parcours
parlementaire devrait intervenir en à la
fin de l'année décembre prochain vous
vous inspirez très directement vous êtes
dans la continuité de ce de cette loi
européenne entre guillemets c'est le
même état d'esprit il s'agit là aussi de
d'inverser le rapport de force oui c'est
c'est la continuité du travail engagé au
niveau européen mais également en France
avec un certain nombre d'initiatives qui
ont été prises ces dernières années pour
euh euh qu'on puisse établir un ordre
public en ligne pour que les droits et
les devoirs soient respectés pour mettre
fin à la loi du plus fort là j'ai la
liste sous les yeux de des mesures hein
qui sont on va pas toutes les citer il y
en a peut-être une ou deux que vous
souhaitez mettre en avant et qui sont
spécifiques à la France par rapport à ce
qui'est euh la législation européenne
bien sûr et je précise que la
législation européenne ce règlement dont
on vient de parler il s'applique dans
tous les États-membres c'est ça qui fait
sa force d'ailleurs euh sans qu'il ne
soit besoin de le transposer il
Simp au niveau au niveau national
fallait juste établir les
responsabilités des autorités qui vont
faire appliquer le le DSA dans le texte
de loi on les désigne et puis en plus on
prend l'Autorité de régulation
communication électronique et puis l'arc
l'Autorité de régulation de
communication audiovisuelle que vous
responsabil bien sûr qui va être le
point de contact pour la
commission lorsque la commission aura
besoin de savoir si oui ou non au regard
de la loi française euh ces plateformes
se comportent bien et ben c'est l'arcom
euh qui renseignera la la Commission et
qui participera notamment à ce travail
d'enquête et au aux sanctions
éventuelles qui pourront en découler
ensuite dans le projet de loi on a on a
ajouter quelques mesures qui sont
inspirées de notamment de travaux
parlementaires de ces dernières années
pour répondre à des inquiétudes voire
même à des souffrances que ressentent
nos concitoyens sur Internet et qui
finissent par saper ouais à juste titre
leur confiance dans le numérique c'est
d'abord le filtre anti-arnaque c'était
une promesse présidentielle ce sera un
rempart contre les campagnes de SMS et
de Mel fruduleux on a tous reçu ces faux
SMS du compte personnel de formation on
en reçoit encore on a tous hésité à
cliquer parfois on a cliqué et ce sont
18 millions de Français dans notre pays
qui ont été victimes de ce type de
manœuvre frauduleuse deuxème mesure
peut-être la de ure oui la deuxième
mesure c'est la peine de bannissement
des réseaux sociaux c'est quelque chose
de très nouveau dans notre droit qui va
permettre au juge de
décider de suspendre la participation à
un réseau social d'une personne condamné
pour des faits de violence ou de de
suspendre ou bannir des réseaux sociaux
oui c'est la même chose pendant 6 mois
suspendre ou bannir pendant 6
mois justement là peut-être une question
technique parce que effectivement ça
fait partie des des mesure qu'on a pu
lire le le le banissement jusqu'à
potentiellement l'exclusion je crois en
cas de récidive si non c'est 6 mois puis
un an 6 mois puis un an d'accord mais là
on voit qu'on a des problématiques
techniques par rapport au banissement
d'un cyber harceleur si on prend
justement la thématique du soir comment
on peut être sûr que cette personnel va
pas recréer un autre compte avec une
autre identité pour continuer à harceler
d'une autre manière on sait très bien
qu'on crée un compte en quelques
secondes donc comment ça va s'opérer
techniquement justement cette ouis c'est
vrai que c'est une question qui vous a
été posée de nombreuses fois ça oui
alors il y a deux choses la première
c'est que contrairement à ce qu'on
pourrait penser depuis 2004 en France et
la loi pour la confiance dans l'économie
numérique les plateformes ont
l'obligation de conserver certaines de
nos traces numériques il s'agit en
particulier sans rentrer trop dans le
jargon de l'adresse IP de la signature
du navigateur de la signature du
téléphone alors ça suffit pas
nécessairement pour empêcher la la
réinscription sur le réseau social en
utilisant une autre connexion
[Musique]
me parilleurs
lesesê peuent mett en place un certain
nombre de techniques
pour
repérer les comportements de ceux qui se
livrent à ce type de de harcèlement et
qui pourrait les répéter une fois qu'il
se sera inscrit mais le deuxième point
qui est très important et que on a
ajouté à l'Assemblée nationale c'est que
l'auteur qui contournerait la la peine
de bannissement qui se remettrait à à
harceler et même en réalité s'il ne se
remet pas harceler sera lui-même
possible d'une peine de prison et d'une
lourde amende donc il y aura une
responsabilité de la part des des
plateformes pour empêcher la la
réinscription et il y aura une sanction
pour l'auteur qui contournerait la peine
prononcée contre il y a aussi une menure
qui doit vous intéresser tout
particulièrement c'est l'accès au site
pornographique pour les plus jeunes il
est prévu quelque chose dans ce texte à
ce sujet des problématiques technique
évidente aussi là encore ou alors non il
est prévu effectivement je pas parler du
du texte
place mais mais effectivement y a deux
choses différentes qui sont prév dans
texte par rapport à la pornographie il y
a des pouvoirs qui sont donnés à l'arcom
qu'on don on a parlé tout à l'heure de
de blocage administratif dans les cas
effectivement de de sites pornographiqu
qui malgré des injonctions ne mettrai
pas en place un système de vérification
d'âge qui leur a imposé par la loi
depuis 3 ans maintenant hein d qu' qui
ne mettent pas en place et on voit là
toute la difficulté technique non non
non pas du tout en fait non il y a
aucune difficulté technique la technique
c'est vraiment pas difficile ouais plus
la chance que depuis 3 ans comme
effectivement le temps a passé il y a pu
avoir effectivement voilà un marché qui
s'est ouvert he sur la vérification
d'âge et donc maintenant il il y a
vraiment pas mal d'acteurs français ou
étrangers qui se sont positionnés dessus
avec des solutions assez différentes on
va évidemment de plus simple que les
gens imaginent qui est la carte
d'identité ça peut être la carte
bancaire ça peut être de la
reconnaissance biométrique faciale pour
faire cours pour que les gens
comprennent et puis il y a ce qu'on
appelle le la tier de confiance le
double an anonyat qui est un peu ce qui
ce qui se passe quand vous payez en
ligne en fait c'est-à-dire qu'il y a il
y a quelqu'un quand vous payez par
banque en ligne en fait il y a un tiers
qui dit que qui vous permet en fait de
payer quraement voyez c'est pas
directement entre votre banque et le
site donc voilà c'est un peu cette
idée-là qui n'est pas de vérification
d'identité que les gens ne fantasment
pas c'est la vérification d'âge c'estàd
qu'on va extraire de votre identité qui
concerne qui a plein d'éléments en juste
votre date de naissance enfin même pas
la date de naissance en réité mais bon
une preuve de votre âge qu'on va ensuite
pouvoir donner euh au site
pornographique pour pouvoir euh l'ouvrir
voilà tout ça pour dire que
techniquement il y a aucun problème
la difficulté qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est
tout simplement des des sites
pornographiques qui refusent de façon
tout à fait consciente d'appliquer cette
loi pour des raisons à nouveau
évidemment économique euh la justice qui
a du mal à assumer le rôle qui lui est
donné de constater de l'illégalité et
donc de mettre en place les mesures qui
derrière vont et que en France quand un
site est déclaré illégal il rentre dans
un liste de sites qui sont illégaux et
que donc doivent être nécessairement
obligatoirement bloqué par les
fournisseurs d'accès internet donc ceux
qui vous donnent accès Internet ce qui
veut dire qu'à partir un site est
considéré comme illégal vous ne pouvez
plus y avoir accès en France voilà donc
ça c'est à la justice heureusement
puisqu'on est dans un état de droit donc
c'est à la justice de le constater et
donc de de le mettre en place et c'est
vrai que ça fait 2 ans maintenant qu'un
bras de fer voilà effectivement est en
place entre des associations comme les
nôtres et et la justice pour les les les
contraindre ce qui paraît un peu esque
mais bon à appliquer la loi et donc
évidemment potentiellement à bloquer les
sites pornographiques le temps qui met
en place un système de vérification
d'âge euh voilà donc j'espère que dans 2
ans on se dira mais tu te rends compte
qu'en 2023 encore les mineurs pouvent
voir de la pornographie parce et
j'espère donc on sera passé à autre
chose de ce projet de loi que que vous
portez hein jeannoël barreot il y a
aussi une proposition de loi
préalablement qui concernait cette fois
l'autorité parendale pour les jeunes de
moins de 15 ans ça a été proposé
d'ailleurs par un député Renaissance je
crois à l'Assemblée
national et vous dites oui là aussi
c'est faisable mais il va falloir quand
même considér blement changer la donne
pour qu'on y arrive c'est-à-dire un
contrôle parental pour les moins de 15
ans oui plus partagé sur cette c'est
peut-être pas le lieu d'en parler mais
mais ça fait partie du lot quand même
c'est que la majorité numérique elle a
été créée en réalité par par le rgpd he
donc elle est elle elle elle précède
cette cette loi c'est le rgpd qui a qui
a rgputêtre alors c'est le règlement sur
la protection des données qui existe
depuis 2018 en Europe entière c'est
comme le DSA c'est un texte européen qui
protège nos données personnelles et qui
pour les mineurs effectivement euh
détermine l'âge à partir duquel un
mineur peut donner son accord tout seul
pour la collecte de ces données et n'a
plus besoin de l'autorité de l'accord
des parents pour comme pour plein
d'autres choses dans la vie euh
malheureusement l'Europe n'a pas été
capable au niveau européen de trancher
sur un âge donc il a laissé chaque pays
déterminer son propre âge qui est assz
compliqué donc en FR voilà on a laissé
15 ans donc la majorité nominéqueon l'
défini à ce moment-là effectivement le
texte là a voulu aller un peu plus loin
pour que ça devienne systématique pour
s'inscrire sur les réseaux sociaux et
donc qu' faille donner euh l'accord
parental pour pour s'inscrire sur les
réseaux sociaux entre 13 et 14 ans
finalement puisque 15 ans la majoritéque
là pour le coup c'est pas évident c'est
pas du tout technique hein c'est juste
comment on s'assure que celui qui dit
être le parent et bien le parent puisque
ça n'a de sens qu'à ce moment-là et donc
comment on sait qu'il faut demander
l'accord du parent donc ça veut dire
qu'on doit savoir déjà qu'il a l'âge
auquel on doit demander l'accord des
parents donc tout ça fait que c'est
assez complexe malgré tout à mettre en
place et que je pense qu'on met un peu
la charue avant les Bleus donc déjà
essayons de régler le problème de la
pornographie et la vérification d'âge et
ensuite on pourra M cette proposition de
loi dont on parle n'est pas encore
définitivement adoptée he non plus au
Parlement peut-être juste une précision
par elle est définitivement adoptée oui
juste une toute petite précision parce
que je pense que peut-être ici vous avez
on a des enfants ceux qui nous regardent
ont des adolescents il y a quand même
une réalité c'est que normalement sur un
réseau social il faut avoir plus de 13
ans pour pouvoir s'y inscrire c'est déjà
quelque chose qui est normalement établi
or dans les faits on sait très bien que
déjà le le taux d'équipement du
smartphone c'est 9 ans et 9 mois donc il
est de plus en plus précoce et
d'ailleurs c'est une étude i enfance qu'
l'a révélé il a quelques semaines on
voit qu'on a une part de 9 12 ans 9 11
ans qui sont en augmentation constante
et que dès 10 ans on peut être sur un
réseau social à 11 ans encore plus à 12
ans encore plus donc il y a des textes
il y a il y a ce qu'on aimerait et puis
il y a une réalité du terrain qu'il faut
pas occulter qu'il faut regarder en face
et la réalité du terrain c'est que pour
l'instant les plateformes laissent
s'inscrire à peu près qui veut sur une
sur sur ces outils que les adolescents
eux-mêmes déjà par désir de
divertissement de sociabilité ont besoin
d'y être ou se sentent et bien avec une
une envie de pouvoir vivre une
expérience adolescente aujourd'hui
l'expérience adolescente elle se vit
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux on l'a
suffisamment dit un réseau social c'est
pas unere qui caractérise cette
génération exactement donc je trouve que
parfois il y a pas je dirais pas une
hypocrisie mais c'est assez compliqué
d'aller chercher une obligation des
plateformes d'âge 15 ans 13 ans
lorsqu'on voit déjà que dans un état de
fait dans une très grande proportion à
11 ans on est sur snapchat on est sur
TikTok on va pas revenir en arrière
simplement il y a une chose sur laquelle
vous n'avez pas voulu aller c'est le
terrain de la levée de
l'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux bon
il y a des députés ont déposé des
amendements il y a une machine arrière
bon pourquoi est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
engagé sur ce terrain alors d'abord sur
le sujet précédent parce que c'est vrai
que ça c'est soulevé dans ce film sous
le couvert de l'anonymat effectivement
on peut
faire
d'Any attendez on va laisser passer par
sur le sujet précédent ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre et en résumé que ce soit
sur la question de l'accès de nos
enfants à des contenus réservés aux
adultes et à la pornographie en
particulier ou leur accès aux réseaux
sociaux ou leur accès en réalité à de
nombreux contenus qui sont sur Internet
la mère des batailles qui n'est pas une
bataille technique mais une bataille
juridique que nous qui qui est une
bataille très dure parce qu'évidemment
nous avons contre nous des vents
contraires puissants et des puissances
de l'argent qui bataillent et qui milit
pour nous empêcher d' parvenir c'est la
vérification
d'âge notre objectif prioritaire c'est
de l'imposer au site pornographique mais
c'est une bataille juridique épique un
combat dans laquel dans lequel la France
est aux avant-postes et prend tous les
risques mais ensuite viendront d'autres
combats pour que la vérification d'âge
se généralise partout et tout le temps
ça c'est pour laite sur l'anonymat oui
l'anonymat n'existe pason dit bah
finalement il il y a qu'à empêcher
l'anonymat et puis on va on va peut-être
régler un certain nombre de problème
peut-être un peu naïvement sans doute un
peu naïvement je le C l'anonyat n'existe
pas sur Internet comme je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure les plateformes ont
l'obligation de conserver certaines de
vos données pour pouvoir répondre aux
réquisitions des forces de l'ordre et de
l'autorité judiciaire quand vous prenez
l'affaire Mila quand vous prenez
l'affaire osi quand vous la prenez
l'affaire de Eddie de Preto dans les
trois cas des personnalités des des
jeunes femmes des jeunes hommes qui sont
des personnalités ou des des artistes
qui se sont fait cyberhceler et bien
leurs cyberhceleurs sont vu euh euh
pronon ont vu prononcer à leur rcontre
des peines de prison ferme dans le cas
des émeutes et des violences urbaines du
début de mois du mois de juillet vous
avez des dizaines de condamnations à des
peines de prison ferme qui ont été
prononcé à l'encontre d'individus qui
derrière leur écran euh ont commis des
délits de propagation de la haine et de
la violence en ligne sans jamais mettre
un pied dehors pourquoi et bien parce
que les enquêteurs sur
réquisition des procureurs et de la
justice sont allés chercher ces euh
délinquants jusque chez eux pour pouvoir
les traduire devant la justice et pour
que la justice puisse prononcer à le
rcontre des condamnations nul ne peut
impunément propager la haine et la
violence en ligne on peut toujours vous
retrouver lorsque vous commettez de tels
délits alors ça prend plus ou moins de
temps euh la justice a été pendant
longtemps paralysée mais je rappelle
qu'avec la loi de programmation de la
justice nous allons recruter plus de
personnel en 5 ans que la justice n'en a
recruté en 20 ans oui que AC la loi de
programmation de ministn qui soit
peut-être plus spécialisé dans ce
domaine donc euh il n'y a pas d'adonyat
sur Internet et et on et et pour pour
pour peu qu'on en ait les moyens on
retrouve toujours les auteurs il nous
reste 3 minutese non mais juste voilà
vous avez entièrement raison il y a pas
d'anonymation sur internet et je pense
que c'est important de le rappeler parce
qu'on peut encore le lire à droite à
gauche dans les médiasû néanmoins je
vais et et tous les cas que vous avez
donné sont sont juste on a pu retrouver
les auteurs là je me mets à la place
peut-être de de l'adolescent qui nous
regarde ce soir de l'adolescente surtout
qui nous regarde ce soir et qui se fait
cber harcelé au quotidien bien sûr elle
peut appeler y enfance mais on est
d'accord que par rapport au nombre de
victimes qu'il y a au quotidien il y a
pas une procédure qui est engagée à
chaque fois comme vous venez de les
mentionner sur des affaires qui ont été
assez médiatiques it de Préto connu et
cetera alors après voilà donc on peut
qu'est-ce que vous répondez justement à
cette je sais pas cette fille de 11 ans
12 ans qui se fait sibar harceler qui
entend que effectivement la personne qui
harcèle pourrait peut-être se retrouver
en trison parce qu'il y a pas d'anonymat
mais qui pour autant voit que la
personne continue vous voyez ce que je
veux dire il y a aussi de PO de mesur
pense que il faut que chacun prenne
conscience de ce que c'est que le droit
et le devoir de chacun sur internet
qu'il faut que chacun ait bien
conscience qu'on est en train d'accroîre
considérablement la pression qui est sur
les plateformes et je crois qu'il faut
que chacun adopte un réflexe civique
c'est que lorsque l'on est victime mais
même lorsque l'on est témoin de violence
et de haine sur internet il y a une
chose à faire c'est de signaler signaler
ça veut dire cliquer sur le petit bouton
en haut à droite euh de du contenu du
message de de la vidéo euh pour signaler
qu'il y a probablement un contenu
illicite c'est la seule manière
d'activer la la responsabilité des
plateformes et euh et c'est et c'est
donc un véritable acte civique lorsque
vous êtes témoins ou victime de
cyberhcèlement et de cyberharcèlement
scolaire Vous signalez à la plateforme
et ensuite vous contactez le 3018
c'est-à-dire la la la hline qui est un
numéro de téléphone mais aussi une
application qui est opérée par
l'association i enfance et je le dis et
dites-le autour de vous parce que dans
bien des cas que nous avons connu ces
derniers mois tragique où des enfants
ont même fini par se donner la mort oui
et bien de enfants se donne la mort
suite à un harcèlement scolaire
aujourd'hui en France il faut que nos
auditeurs il faut que nos auditeurs
sachent que la responsabilité des
plateformes qui contribue à la diffusion
à la prolifération des contenus de cyber
harcèlement scolaire ne peut être engagé
que si ces contenus leur on été signaler
donc il convient de signaler massivement
les contenus illicites que vous voyez
transiter sur bon mais c'est très
concret je vais vous laisser le mot de
la fin peut-être ou là grande
responsabilité al le mot de la fin il y
a peut-être quelque chose dans ce texte
qu'a défendu J le Barou qui manque à vos
yeux non bien sûr que non
ilieur ministre oui parce que en France
a des demandes à des revendications oui
oui mais il reconnaître qu'on travaille
très bien avec avec notamment jeannoël
Barot et le gouvernement et voilà dans
ce senslà parce qu'effectivement la
France est quand même très moteur sur
sur ces
sujetsl évidemment en collaboration mais
il va falloir qu'on travaille avec les
réseaux sociaux c'est ce qui d'ailleurs
dit dans dans le reportage et notamment
à la fin c'estàd que on peut pas faire
sans eux ils ont une responsabilité
qu'il faut qu'on engage qui est de plus
en plus forte en en réalité c'est ça le
texte le DSA ne change pas grand chose
mais renforce leur responsabilité c'est
les rend vraiment acteurs alors qu'ils
ont cherché à se défausser pendant des
années donc ils n'ont plus le choix que
de faire avec nous effectivement et et
et nous il faut qu'effectivement on se
serve de cette responsabilité pour pour
les engagés qui protège effectivement
tous les utilisateurs parce que les
mineurs sont victimes mais il y a plein
d'adultes aussi qui sont victimes de de
cyberhcèlement c'est un traumatisme
énorme et on voit bien qu'on soit une
personnalité publique privée un jeune un
adulte c'est totalement traumatisant
d'être d'être cyberhcelé se sent
vraiment persécuté donc voilà donc il y
a moi je refuse qu'on dise qu'on peut
rien faire c'est pas vrai on peut faire
plein de choses le problème c'est que
les gens ne connaissent pas ce qu'il
faut faire et du coup n'agissent pas les
moyen donc effectivement je vais prêcher
pour ma paroisse contacter le 3018
appeler le 3018 télécharger
l'application 308 on a une capacité de
signaler nous au service de modération
directement des réseaux sociaux et ils
peuvent nous répondre ils nous répondent
toujours et ils nous répondent très
rapidement donc voilà donc ça si vous
avez un enfant adolescent victime
faites-le vous ne risquez rien à part
éventuellement une bonne solution bon et
la suite nous dira si l'Union européenne
la France a réussi à un temps soit peu à
à gagner à commencer à gagner ce bras de
fer qui nous a opposé et qui nous oppose
toujours hein aux grands opérateurs que
sont les les garfames sur le sujet qui
nous concernait aujourd'hui un grand
merci vraiment à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à à ce débadoc vos réactions
ça sera sur hashtagdbadoc alors là à mon
avis il va y en avoir un certain nombre
merci d'avance hein de réagir à ce que
sont les les réactions suite à cette
émission merci aussi à sel Mali qui m'a
aidé comme elle accoutumé à préparer
cette émission prochain rendez-vous avec
des badooc ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat à
[Musique]
bientôt